[موسيقى]
أنت هو بلدي القطعة الأولى والغابة xlii
هل تعمل جويس
نسخة لنفسي ويمنحها
ننضم إليهم لركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية و
ثم الرجل لديه جسر هل تعلقه فيه
مصر سائح
تشينغ هاي كانت المرة الأولى لي بشكل جيد
منذ ما يقرب من 20 عامًا
نية الوردي النمس في عصير بلدي و
كان رقائق الفلاش
من
نصب تفعل الأميال والنظام
النصب العظيم جيت فان boxtel و aboe
simbel بالطبع وبقي هكذا واحد
من أي وقت مضى على الرغم من أنه يبدو خرائط
[موسيقى]
euhm أدناه منذ وقت طويل بلدي
شفاه لطيفة أكتوبر منذ حوالي 15
سنوات وكل هذا الوقت لم أفعله أبدًا
في المعركة لتكون هنا وسائل الإعلام أكثر
لوتو
نعم كيف مع الدعم والكثير
الحل ولذا فهو يعرف توم دبليو سي ديه
في اختبار هاتفك يمكن أن يكون جاكوزي
شيء من البيرة الألبانية المقلية الجسر
هنا والاكتئاب بلدي الإنترنت دي بورد
من أي وقت مضى لأنك تعرف أن هذا الشعور
جينا
كان احباط الخلفية البيضاء على أي حال لم يكن كذلك
خائف
قراءة بيبينو في توماس المتشكك
تقدم جحر الأسرة آو هي فقط كيف
فهموا أن كيس أيدين يرى أي شيء و
تشعر بالأمان للذهاب معها حرفيًا
متأكد جدًا من أنك تستطيع إعلامي أكثر
هل انت مستعد
عبر اختر هنا لأي تقنية قديمة
الذين يوصون بالمجيء إلى هنا والأجمل
جبار الفرنسي أرنو دي بيج الهدف لذلك
بوابة المعرفة
اجعل العرض ساطعًا مرة أخرى ربما
لا تظهر لي أحب أصدقائي راي
بواسطة جيمس كوفي بأربع مرات على وتر
منذ وقت طويل لا ملحمة الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الأخرى revery
ذهبنا من الحلوى الصمغية النهائية
سحق الطقس السلس والمعرفة
من يرونهم يتشكلون ويلمسون
نعم تعني الذات إيجابيا سام ما أنا
فقط صعبة معها وتأتي تجربتي
لمصر للقيام بإعادة توقيت مي أميغو
هذه الرحلة
[موسيقى]